uh delete is here um he is going to give
some brief remarks at the top about the
sanctions announcement today he has a
hard out so he's only going to be able
to take a few questions today but we're
grateful to have you here so i'll kick
it over to you
russia's long previewed invasion of
ukraine has begun and so too has our
response
today the president responded swiftly
and in lockstep with allies and partners
the speed and coordination was historic
in previous sanctions regimes it took
weeks and months to mount a decisive
response this time we announced our
first tranche of sanctions in less than
a day and in lockstep with allies and
partners in the european union the
united kingdom
canada japan and australia
let me say a few words about the details
of the package
first
hello
there's no easy segue from that
close your ears
first after consultations overnight with
germany
russia's nordstream 2 natural gas
pipeline will not become operational
that's an 11 billion investment in a
prized gas pipeline controlled by russia
that will now go to waste
and it sacrifices what would have been a
cash cow for russia's coffers
but it's not just about the money
this decision will relieve russia's
geostrategic chokehold over europe
through its supply of gas and it's a
major turning point in the world's
energy independence from russia
second
we've demonstrated the potency of our
financial sanctions and make make no
mistake this is only the sharp edge of
the pain we can inflict
in lockstep with our allies we're fully
blocking from the global financial
system
the fifth largest russian
uh financial institution veb
this is a glorified piggy bank for the
kremlin that holds more than 50 billion
dollars in assets we're also fully
blocking prombaya's bank
uh this is a bank that holds 35 billion
dollars in assets it finances the
activities of the russian military
in plain english
full full block means these banks can no
longer make any transactions with the
u.s nor with europe as europe matched
our actions
and their assets and our respective
financial systems will be frozen
and let me be totally clear
no russian financial institution is safe
if the invasion proceeds
we are ready to press a button to take
action on the two largest russian
financial institutions which
collectively hold almost 750 billion in
assets or more than half of the total in
the russian banking system
third together with our allies we've
also cut off the russian government the
russian central bank and russian
sovereign wealth funds from new
financing from the u.s and europe the
kremlin can no longer raise money
from the u.s or europe and its new debt
can no longer trade on u.s or european
financial markets
fourth we've fully sanctioned a group of
russian elites and their family members
these individuals share in the corrupt
gains of the kremlin and they will now
share in the pain
other russian elites and their family
members are now on notice that
additional actions could be taken on
them as well
i also want to take a minute to address
a key part of the president's speech on
energy markets
we were deliberate to direct the pain of
our sanctions towards the russian
economy not ours
none of our measures are designed to
disrupt the flow of energy to global
markets and we are now executing a plan
in coordination with major oil producers
and major oil consumers to secure the
stability of global energy supplies
let me just end where i started this was
the beginning of an invasion and this is
the beginning of our response the
actions we took today were only the
first tranche if putin escalates further
we will escalate further using financial
sanctions and export controls which
we've yet to unveil
but which are fully prepared to
implement with allies and partners
across the world lastly
make no mistake our response goes well
beyond sanctions and export controls
we're continuing to fortify nato's
eastern flank to reinforce a sacred
article 5 commitment to defend every
inch of nato territory just today the
president announced that additional
troops and equipment will be shifted
within europe to the baltics we'll
continue to provide defensive assistance
to ukraine already over the past year we
provided 650 billion dollars to this
effect the most of any year and we'll
continue to work with allies and
partners to provide economic assistance
to ukraine
uh with the idea being we want to create
a successful alternative in ukraine to
russian-style kleptocracy which may be
putin's greatest fear of all
thank you
thank you can you uh speak a little bit
more about the energy component and what
tools do you have in the tools given
that there's been a network ongoing now
for several months to control
the price increases that we're seeing
for uh for gasoline in particular what
can you do to help
energy prices not fight the way that
president biden appears to worry as they
will yeah so this is an ongoing effort
and a sensitive effort i can give you a
bit
a bit of detail on what that involves
number one it involves coordinating uh
our our actions with major energy
producers we all have uh reserves at our
disposal and those reserves could help
support the supply of energy worldwide
number two uh we're working closely with
major energy producers
many of them have several of them have
the spare capacity to provide supply to
global energy markets and to balance the
market in the event of any supply
disruption
number three we can work with energy
companies to surge their capacity to
supply energy to the market particularly
as prices rise
and number four we can be very clear
that if president putin weaponizes
energy supply
it will be met with massive consequences
and it will only accelerate the
diversification of europe and the world
away from russian energy
quickly to the decision to what seems to
be de-linking
the the sanctions initially the
president was signaling if there is an
invasion or a further invasion
that the sanctions would come full stop
one swoop now we're seeing sort of more
of a tit-for-tat
approach you're warning here today that
president putin goes uh further so will
the sanctions can you walk us through
that process at all it seems like the
u.s is now breaking its sanctions
package into chunks whereas the
expectation has been that it would come
all at once
yeah well look today's today's package
is a severe action i walk through the
elements of it with nordstrom the
financial sanctions sovereign debt and
the elites number two it's just the
beginning this was the beginning of an
invasion this is just the beginning of
our response but number three and this
really gets to your question i think
most fundamentally um
no one should think that it's our goal
to max out on sanctions sanctions are
not an end to themselves they serve a
higher purpose
and that purpose is to deter and prevent
they're meant to prevent and deter a
large-scale invasion of ukraine that
could involve the seizure of major
cities including kiev they're meant to
prevent large-scale human suffering that
could involve tens of thousands of
casualties in a conflict and they're
meant to prevent the installation of a
puppet government controlled by moscow
that subjugates the will of ukraine and
prevents the people of ukraine from
choosing their own destiny and setting
their own course that's what this is all
about
what's it going to take to target putin
directly
i'm not going to i'm not going to
telegraph exactly what it would take and
under what circumstances that would
occur but no option is off the table as
the president said the eu president said
today this is the most dangerous moment
in european security in a generation so
if not today when what
look uh as i say we mounted a very
significant response today we can
escalate that response further there are
a number of actions we can take using
financial sanctions export controls
fortifying our eastern flank uh helping
ukraine defend itself helping each other
deal with the costs and consequences of
russia's invasion and most importantly
having a shared confidence among allies
in our way of life our economic model
our political model if russia wants to
sequester itself from western technology
the western economy uh and and from
western financial markets that is a bad
strategic choice for russia but we're
going to step up in solidarity to
advance our values and principles
thank you you mentioned that sanctions
are meant to deter and prevent but the
fact of the matter is the sanctions
you're announcing today and that's last
night did not deter or prevent russia
russia's actions yesterday over the
weekend what gives you any confidence
that the remaining sanctions that
haven't been imposed yet can deter or
prevent a further russian invasion
and aggression in ukraine well look it's
it's it's uh it's day one and
president putin has choices to make we
have choices to make our job our job is
to manage risks and to impose
consequences uh for a further escalation
of this conflict by president putin we
can do that through financial sanctions
we can do that through export controls
we can do that through fortifying nato's
eastern flank we can do that through
providing defensive assistance to
ukraine we can do that by being prepared
for any energy market impact that occurs
from russia's choices those are the
choices that are within our disposal and
let me just take a step back and talk
about sanctions you know we have we have
principles that matter in terms of how
we design
a sanctions package
they need to be
powerful enough to demonstrate our
resolve
and the capacity to impose overwhelming
costs they should be calibrated such
that we can maximize coordination with
our allies and partners
they should maintain flexibility so we
can escalate or de-escalate depending on
what putin does
they should be responsible so that we
avoid unwanted spillovers to the us and
global economy and they need to be
sustainable they work overtime not on
day one
[Music]
thank you go ahead
thank you
i know that you just talked about all
the actions that you're taking to
counter
any oil shortages that might drive up
gas prices but today the president
himself was very blunt about how they
could impact americans so can you just
give us a sense of when americans might
feel
a difference when they fill up their gas
tanks and then secondly
to follow up on what zeke was just
asking both you and the president said
today that these sanctions
will be in response
will be if if putin escalates you will
escalate so that sounds like they are
going to be in response now and not
meant to deter so do you still view them
as being
a deterrent or are they just a
punishment at this point
yeah so the first question on energy
markets and the impact of our actions
and when they'll take effect in markets
look
again i i don't want to go into
specifics but there are actions that
energy consumers can take with their
strategic reserves their actions that
energy producers can take in terms of
their spare capacity their actions that
energy producers can undertake to
increase their production of energy in
the current circumstance and
i'm not going to give you a timeline but
the collective power of those actions
and all the other tools and authorities
that are at our disposal plus diplomatic
diplomatic maneuvers that are at
that are at our disposal collectively we
think will be effective in bringing down
uh the price of gas and the price of
he will oil back i promise and i promise
he would not be too late for his meeting
so thank you so much for doing that okay
um i apologize to those of you who did
not get questions from delete we will
have him back and we will make him
available in other capacities as well to
all of you i have one very unrelated but
still very important item for you at the
top and then we'll get back to our uh
discussion um today in arizona interior
secretary deb holland announced the
interior department's plan to fulfill
settlements of indian water rights
claims using historic funding from
president biden's bipartisan
infrastructure law the infrastructure
law provides 2.5 billion dollars to
implement the indian water rights
settlement completion fund which will
help deliver long-promised water
resources to tribes and a foundation for
future economic development for entire
communities dependent on common water
resources following feedback from the
tribal consul from tribal consultations
the department will allocate 1.7 billion
dollars this year alone from the
infrastructural law to enact uh to
enacted settlements that have
outstanding federal payments necessary
to complete their terms uh with that
zeke why don't you kick us off and we
will get around to as many people as
possible and i realize it's already late
go ahead thanks jen um how many walks
through the events the last 24 hours
last night a senior administration
official uh background call with
reporters briefed uh a briefing on the
administrative response and said the
russians occupied these regions since
2014 and that russian troops moving into
the donbass would not end up not of its
uh would not itself be a new step
and didn't use the word invasion this
morning
uh the deputy national security adviser
said invasion the president to see the
invasion
what changed in the last 24 hours what
did you see on the ground that changed
the us government's assessment of what
is actually happening
sure well i'm not going to i know this
isn't exactly what you're asking but
just to set the precedent here i'm not
going to be confirming military
movements from the podium now or at any
point probably but what i can tell you
is what we looked at is the events of
the last less than 24 hours zeke right
and what we have seen is president putin
setting up a rationale to take more
territory by force what we're basing
that on including the comments of the
deputy national security adviser this
morning and then the president's
comments later in the afternoon is a
couple of things one vladimir putin
announced yesterday that he was
basically planning to carve out a chunk
of ukraine by recognizing two regions of
ukraine as independent he brazenly
asserted these regions are no longer
part of ukrainian sovereign territory
last night he authorized russian forces
to deploy into these regions today he
sought authorizations authorization from
the duma for the russian military to use
force outside of russian territory and
today he asserted that these regions
actually extend deeper into ukraine
claiming larger areas currently under
jurisdiction of the ukrainian government
so what we're seeing there and as for
anybody who read or paid attention to
his lengthy speech last night is the
rationale to go much further that is
what we are also watching very closely
and this comp for this combination of
reasons we see this as the beginning of
a further invasion of ukraine but we
look at and we assess over the course of
a short period of time
but right now could you say whether or
not the us government believes that
there's been additional deployments of
russian forces active forces across the
border into into ukraine within their
years but additional forces i'm not
going to get into military uh
assessments of military movements from
here
separate the president and we've talked
americans in the last several weeks that
they have to they should be prepared to
bear the cost of standing up for ukraine
sovereignty
there's been a lot of conversation about
this and it's something you can maybe
speak to
why should americans uh you know feel
that they have to if that is a cost that
they should have to bear and that should
affect their lives and how much should
they be prepared for this you know the
geopolitical crisis impact their
day-to-day life well i think what
hopefully the american people who are
tuning into this or have been tuning
into this we'll see is that the
president of the united states and in
his entire uh national security
apparatus have been rallying the world
and standing up against the efforts of
russia to invade and take and carve out
a chunk of another country for their own
um and that is the world is standing
with the united states against the
actions of president putin now why does
that matter i realize that's what you're
asking me why does that matter to the
american people that should matter
because that is a fundamental value that
we as a country stand up
for and we stand up against that type of
action that goes back to world war ii uh
and and we have repeatedly throughout
history been leaders in the world and
rallying support for any efforts to
seize uh territory from another country
what the when the president spoke to the
american people last week it was very
important to him to be very direct and
clear and straightforward with them
about what this could mean as we looked
to what the impact of an invasion could
mean and also what the impact of
sanctions could mean and the fact that
standing up for values
is not without cost including in this
case including potentially in this
scenario now as philippe just conveyed
what the president has said to his
national security team is he wants to
leave no stone unturned he wants them to
take every step possible to
tap into the resources of global
suppliers
to present to him
any option that will reduce the impact
on the american people and even as he's
looking at sanctions he is taking that
into account but this is about standing
up for american values and making and he
wanted to make clear to them what impact
that could have
thank you jen given what secretary
blinken just announced about his meeting
with um lavrov on thursday is a summit
between the president and putin out of
the question now
well we're never going to completely
close the door to diplomacy i don't
think uh the the secretary of state did
that either but just to build on what he
just said uh diplomacy can't succeed
unless russia changes course and as he
said it wouldn't be appropriate for him
to have a meeting
with his counterpart
at this point in time foreign minister
lavrov and it was always intended
that any engagement with president putin
would follow that so at this point that
is certainly not in the plans
what would it take to get that
conversation back to the table to
reconsider um a meeting between the two
leaders well de-escalation that's what
it would take
the escalation means moving troops it
means de-escalating from what the steps
they continue to take on a daily basis
appear to be
quickly
how many supreme court nominees has the
president interviewed by this point um
that was a wink um i appreciate your
question i understand weija why you're
asking um we are of course a very short
period of time away from the end of the
month of february the president has not
made a decision about who he's going to
nominate but i'm not still not going to
get into details about the internal
process more to tell soon go ahead peter
thank you jen the president said in the
spring that pentagon generals had
briefed him that the greatest threat
facing america
is global warming is that still the
assessment now that we are facing down a
potential cyber war with russia well uh
let me first say there is no uh well we
are always prepared uh for any threat
that any outside entity or country poses
to the united states it relates to cyber
anything else there is no current
pending threat on as it relates to cyber
uh in terms of the threats you're you're
touching on that was a briefing from the
military so i'd point you to them and so
as far as anybody watching who's seen
the coverage it's very at times
distressing images of
russian military movements the
number one threat facing
the country right now remains global
warming well peter i think it's
important as we're all educating the
public here to convey and reiterate the
president has no intention of sending
u.s troops into ukraine to fight in
ukraine what we are doing is we are
abiding by our obligations to our nato
allies and partners to ensure that they
have the support and the resources uh
that they need and that is our right and
our obligation as the united states okay
and why do you guys think that sanctions
are going to stop putin if his goal
ultimately is to redraw the map so it
looks like it did
70 or 80 years ago what sanction is
going to stop them from doing that well
i i think just to kind of reiterate
maybe something you touched on there for
anyone who watched his speech last night
what he made clear in that speech is
that he doesn't even necessarily or
doesn't recognize the independence of
ukraine as a country and that certainly
gives us an indication of where his
intentions are at this point in time
sanctions can be a powerful tool they
have been in a lot of
moments throughout history and what we
view them as uh as or how we're viewing
them as we're starting high as delete
just conveyed uh here uh in terms of the
significance and the severity of the
sanctions that were announced today uh
yes our intention is to have a deterrent
effect and there are uh well what they
have done to date is completely
unacceptable there are certainly far
worse that could happen what we want to
do is prevent a large-scale invasion
death and destruction across ukraine
devastation to the ukrainian people and
that what happens with sanctions is they
work overtime they're not an end
they're not intended to max out the
beginning they're long-lasting and
sustainable and they're intended to
squeeze but if you look at what is
happening now what president putin has
stated as his intention is he wants to
divide nato the opposite of that has
happened peter he also wanted to uh a
geopolitical project nordstrom 2 to go
forward that has not happened he wants
to make sure there is a a vibrant
economy for the russian people they're
not on that track so his intentions and
his objectives are not playing out so i
guess to follow up on that the president
said before he got here that putin knows
if i am president of the united states
his days of tyranny and trying to
intimidate the united states and those
in eastern europe are over it's two and
a half years later he is intimidating
the united states and those in eastern
europe i'd hardly put it that way i
would look at it actually from the prism
of the united states and president biden
has rallied the world uh rallied europe
uh to stand up against the efforts and
the actions of president putin and we
we've laid out very clearly exactly four
dollar gas five dollar gas however how
you guys think it's going to go
something like that
it's not intimidating you asked me if we
were intimidated by uh president putin
and i think uh the evidence of that
doesn't exist go ahead kristen thank you
jeff if i can try one more time
on sanctions yeah the president of
ukraine on saturday urged called on the
united states and its allies to impose
the toughest sanctions and this all of
these questions suggest president putin
doesn't seem to be deterred at this
point why not choke him russia out
financially right now
as a way to try to stop him
well here's how we or our national
security team looks at sanctions it's a
very good question i think it's actually
a different one that was asked um
is we look at them through a couple of
for a couple of purposes one not that
they are going to be an end on their own
just the announcement of sanctions is
not uh is not going to have the
immediate impact they're not intended to
work that way they're not we're not
they're not intended to max out at the
beginning this is why we've always
intended to have a range of sanctioned
steps that we could plus up to or
escalate to if his behavior and his
actions continue to be escalatory uh and
also if we do all the sanctions now what
is the deterrent effect or impact of
preventing him to take further action
that is what the conversation we've been
in with the global community and that is
how we've been approaching it to date
senator lindsey graham says president is
missing a moment does he run the risk of
being too cautious here with this
tranche approach
when what capacity is he missing the
moment
senator i'll read you the information
in history president biden is not
seizing the moment the sanctions
outlined
did he say that before after we
announced the sanctions
consistently well look i think it's an
important question because what we what
the president announced was the
sanctioning of two enormous financial
systems this uh institutions that is
essentially going to make it more
difficult for people close to president
putin and in the russian elite to do
business and this is just the beginning
people feel the impact when will they
feel the fight well they're going to be
in they're going to be implemented
immediately so
obviously it takes some time but uh but
our effort and our focus is on
implementing them immediately going back
to president biden's statement that he
wants to mitigate the impact on
americans
can you tell americans how much pain
will they feel with this first crunch
well i think what we're looking at here
kristin is of course the impact on um
natural gas producers primarily is in
europe and we're working to help them
too but also on the oil markets and
obviously there are many additional
steps that president putin could take
and what we're seeing is that he has
every intention of taking so i can't
give you a projection of that some of it
depends on what the actions are
americans will feel the impact in the
coming weeks of these rounds again it
really depends on what the steps are
what was announced today was significant
sanctions on russian elite and on
financial institutions there the people
who will be largely impacted are in
russia on those
one more uh swift not in this initial
rule there's not in the initial tranche
but remains on the table
in the next roll out if there needs to
be another rollout i can't give you a
prediction of that but again uh we have
a range of options that remain on the
table um significant uh uh that would
have a significant and uh and
devastating impact on the russian
economy we've already seen in the
russian economy the impact on inflation
there uh and on the markets there of the
expectation of these uh of these
sanctions but all of those options
remain on the table and i can't make a
prediction of what's next go ahead the
president today used words like bizarre
and twisted to describe putin's remarks
does the administration believed on what
they saw in this speech yesterday or in
the last 24 hours if you will that putin
has shown some kind of change in his
state of mind and his demeanor
i wouldn't say we'd characterize it that
way cecilia i mean if you uh for those
of you who read or or watched his speech
last night which was rife with
historical inaccuracy of course
he made clear that he
does not view ukraine not just the areas
he recognized yesterday but the totality
of ukraine as an independent country and
he did and he conveyed that by providing
a lot of revisionist history details
that are not aligned with what has
happened over the last few decades now
we've seen some of that rhetoric if you
look back back to 2008 and even before
then
but it is indicative of uh you know what
of his own belief that he has the right
uh as a of that russia and he has the
right to take the territory to claim uh
territory from another country and we
just don't agree with that obviously if
sanctions don't work then what what else
is in the tool belt at the president's
disposal at this point well uh sanctions
can take a number of formats right um
export controls is certainly one of them
there's many more sanctions that we have
at our disposal swift the swift system
is obviously significant and not in the
first tranche but there's a range of uh
options uh that remain on the table for
sanctions and again as the leap conveyed
but i think this is an important
component for to
to to know is that they're not intended
to have an impact on the fir
the harshest impact on the first day
they're attempted they're they're
planned or they're um uh they're
designed uh to have a squeezing impact
uh over the course of time and we have
many more escalatory steps that we could
take but do you have specific agreements
with countries exporters to ensure
europe has a steady supply of gas or is
that still a work in progress i i
certainly understand your question as
the leap said it's a very at a very
sensitive time in the process right now
but what we're doing right now is
talking both to major natural gas
producers to understand their capacity
and willingness to surge natural natural
gas output which of course is a regional
issue that would have an impact in
europe and also talking as he said to a
range of uh producers uh to uh to help
assess or help reduce the market impact
and the impact on the american public
but i just can't outline any more
details on it for you
the impact that you're on the american
public you mean specifically
americans should expect higher gasoline
yeah energy prices exactly that's that's
what we want the american public to be
aware is a possibility announcing more
oligarchs tomorrow is that the plan
uh i don't have anything to preview for
you at this point in time but i can
certainly check if there's another
trunks coming tomorrow absolutely go
ahead and given that the president
stressed today that diplomacy is still
available but now the blinkin lavrov
meeting is off you just said this future
you know summit between the president
and putin is not in the plans anymore
can you help paint a picture of what
exactly diplomacy looks like in terms of
dealing with russia
well first we still the dorchester
diplomacy still remains open um and it
just as i think our foreign our
secretary of state conveyed it isn't the
appropriate time as russia is taking
escalatory steps uh and preparing to
invade for him to meet with the foreign
minister um and and it had always been
the intention that any engagement with
president putin would be discussed there
and potentially fellow there but there
were never any specific plans or
timeline really in the works for that so
it was really going to be discussed at
that meeting what diplomacy looks like
when we're going to continue to engage
with our european partners of course
and we will continue to
remain open
to to having diplomatic conversations
once if and when they de-escalate it
diplomatic conversation so certainly
between president biden and president
putin
well of course that remains an option
and as we said i think over the course
of the last few days he's always going
to be open to having leader to leader
conversations but this isn't the time to
do it when and we said this at the time
as well when they are when president
putin is overseeing the uh invasion of a
of a sovereign country
what is the us assessment right now of
russian invasion into keith is that uh
considered an immediate danger right now
it can it is considered i'm not going to
give you a timeline but it can it's
considered a real possibility yes go
ahead thanks for weeks jake sullivan and
other club officials have said that the
administration the white house has
learned the lessons of 2014 and you will
uh enact
in sanctions you will enact starfly and
stay high rather than gradually escalate
as you talk about the chunks of
different tranches it seems you're doing
the opposite why is that the approach
that you're taking not true actually
we actually didn't sanction these type
of financial institutions back in 2014
and it took several weeks to sanction
these type of institutions
more in terms of the theory of the case
that instead of doing it in pieces where
you start and then continue to add on
the lessons that jake and others have
signaled was that you start high and
stay high
instead of doing it more peacefully well
that's exactly what we're doing so the
announcement that was made today about
these financial institutions is more
significant that was than what was done
in 2014 and we would only build further
from here so that is starting high and
staying high
good
what russian actions would trigger the
fullest extent of u.s sanctions
i'm just not going to detail uh what
exact reaction will be to each action
obviously we have a range of options at
our disposal uh they're all remain on
the table and our preference is of
course de-escalation not instituting
more sanctions
is the administration confident that
sanctions and export control can or will
be enough to turn to deter putin and can
you go into any more detail about what
those export controls might look like i
i can't go into specific more specifics
just a range of options around the table
and obviously export control actions
would have a significant uh additional
impact on the economy uh there uh in
terms of tell me your first part of your
question again yeah just is the
administration confident that sanctions
and export controls can deter putin
part of what sanctions are is they have
they they're intended to be a deterrent
but they are also intended to have a
squeezing uh significant impact on the
economy that is felt over a sustainable
period of time that makes it more
difficult to continue those behaviors
and those actions uh they're not they're
not intended or designed to uh to be an
end when they're initially announced um
so that those are the range of options
we have at our disposal and there will
continue to be a growing impact go ahead
thanks the president said last week that
he was hoping to maybe work with
congress on some sort of proposal to
address energy prices is that still on
the table or is this focused now on
certain diplomacy with producers and
consumers always on the table what would
that look like uh discussions with
congress
legislation to lower prices and what
kind of policies that is an option but i
don't have anything to detail for you at
this point in time another subject the
u.s and several countries are close to
reaching a nuclear deal with iran
what's the likelihood of an agreement
you know this week in your view and
would the u.s agree to a deal that does
not include the release of u.s and
british prisoners held by iran
well uh let me let me start with your
second question because this isn't a
really important one but the discussions
on unjustly detained and innocent
americans remain separate from the jcpoa
talks a special
envoy mali has reiterated it's very hard
for us to imagine getting back into the
nuclear deal or agreeing to kind of a
new iteration of the deal to the point
of your question while four instant
americans and others are being held
hostage uh by iran uh it's really a
matter of urgency to bring the detainees
home we want it to be resolved
immediately but is happening from a
through a separate channel those
conversations in terms of the status of
the jcpoa talks we have made substantial
progress or substantial progress has
been made over the last week or so and
is continuing to be a made
nothing is agreed until everything is
agreed and so until then i'm not going
to give you a rosy assessment
but it is of course good that
substantial progress has been made
if ron shows seriousness we believe we
can and should reach an understanding
and mutual return to full implementation
of the jcpoa
is the president concerned at all about
the convoy of truckers that's making its
way to washington and has he taken any
sort of steps to protect
yes we've actually been um been
monitoring uh this closely the
department of homeland security and the
administration are tracking reports of a
potential convoy that may be planning to
travel to several u.s cities including
washington d.c
we have been working including from uh
dr lisherwood randall here as well as
our homeland security department with
closely with our federal state and local
partners to continuously assess the
threat environment and keep our
communities safe
and our efforts uh include enhanced
intelligence sharing a critical incident
response plan uh for the u.s capitol a
regional security assessment and a
simulation experiment that developed
data-driven recommendations to bolster
regional security so we are closely
monitoring closely watching and working
with state and local authorities uh let
me go ahead great first just want to
thank everybody i know it's late who's
uh we're eliminating our questions so
that more people can yes sure so i
appreciate that and if anybody needs to
go for a hit or anything nobody will
take it personally i know some people
have go ahead so um one question of
course um on ukraine first of all duleep
said just now that today's sanction
package is quote just the beginning of
it
does that mean if nothing changes you
expect more sanctions or what does that
mean just the beginning of it it means
we have a range of additional options
that we have the ability to take and if
president putin continues to escalate so
will we
look into the state of the union
when was the last time president biden
spoke to a member of congress about any
item in the buildback better agenda he
has a range of conversations all the
time but i'm not going to detail the
timeline of those for you
go ahead thanks jen when can we expect a
more detailed explanation from the white
house about how it would plan to bring
down energy prices
well i think as the leap just conveyed a
lot of what's happening right now is
sensitive it includes conversations with
foreign counterparts and other major
large global suppliers it also includes
conversations we're continuing to have
with congress and others about what
steps may be at our disposal and the
president is continuing to consider
options so i expect we'll have more to
tell you when any decisions are made
publicly from the russians in the last
several days what
level of concern does the white house
have that the conflict could spill over
out of ukraine
and into some of the other nations that
the u.s has vowed to protect militarily
and are part of nato well without making
any prediction of that what i can tell
you is that one of the steps we've taken
including an announcement that the
department of defense made today about
uh plussing up of an additional 800
personnel to the baltic region from
italy is that we take our uh our
commitments to our nato allies and
partners seriously and we are going to
continue to take steps to plus up their
support
and ensure that they know that they have
the backing of the united states but i'm
not going to make any other predictions
of that go ahead thanks a lot um
that was a little scary go ahead
mcgurk and state department's amos coach
i hope i didn't talk but it's okay yes i
just wanted to ask what concrete
assurances were they able to secure on
on managing potential market pressures
uh from saudi arabia i certainly
understand the question we did confirm
that they went on a trip and they
discussed a range of issues including
yemen uh but also including uh steps to
take to steps we can all take to
coordinate and reduce the impact on the
global market on oil um of oil um but i
can't detail anything further from here
if one of the objectives is not to
disrupt global energy flows yeah and
energy prices are high and rising
how how can russia's bottom line really
be hurt if you don't disrupt
global energy flows
well i think russia's bottom line can be
hurt in a lot of ways including the
range of sanctions we've already
announced today and additional sets of
sanctions that we have at our disposal
should they choose whether it's
sanctioning additional individuals or
taking more significant steps that would
really would impact their financial
market so there's no question we have a
range of tools that could continue to
have crippling impacts on the russian
economy so much of their revenue comes
from oil and energy
i understand what you're saying but we
also have a range of tools that can
impact a range of their uh financial
market have huge financial market
impacts and the president is also
looking at and we're all assessing uh
what steps we can take that will have a
crippling impact on them while reducing
the impact on the american public
go ahead thanks jen i'm just trying to
get a better idea of what the
administration deems to be in escalation
on the part of russia and to
and what would prompt an additional
trump substantiations would it only be
the expansion of russian forces to
non-occupied republics or areas of
ukraine or would it be the continued
deployment of forces to the two
separatist regions that were detailed
yesterday well i think as we've seen
as you've seen hopefully as russia has
taken any escalatory steps we have taken
escalatory
steps on our end in the form of
sanctions and so i'm not going to
outline for you if this then then but i
think if for those of you again who
watched the speech last night the
president president putin direct
attacked ukraine's uh right to exist he
explicitly threatened war unless his
extreme demands were met he gave an
entire speech selling a war to the
russian people our expectation and we
hope we are wrong is that he will
continue to take escalatory actions and
further invade the country and we will
take additional steps in response
um is the administration preparing any
sort of measures for ukrainians already
in the united states such as tps or any
other sort of immigration protections
for those who might not want to go back
sure i don't obviously those decisions
or assessments are made by the
department of homeland security i can't
make a prediction of that at this point
in time uh obviously what we are doing
on the ground is trying to provide a
range of economic humanitarian and
security assistance to the ukrainian
government i understand you're asking
about people who are here and obviously
we are preparing for uh the potential
for uh major humanitarian outflows that
could go into europe uh and have a range
of needs um
and so that is also something we are
closely tracking uh we are also poised
to increase our support to the people
for ukraine should additional
humanitarian needs arise our response
would be based on assessment of the
needs our partners emergency appeals in
coordination with our european allies
and partners but we are assessing the
humanitarian assist situation on the
ground uh very closely and we're going
to continue engage with allies and
partners about any humanitarian needs
that escalate and refugee outflows uh if
they are to continue to occur you know
we're getting close to the deadline i'm
just are skog's interviews done at this
point
i know it's all in process and i know
you know are are they done at this point
the long national process will soon be
over so that's the good news um i'm not
going to detail the status but i can
tell you that the president has not made
a decision yet but we remain on track
for him to make a decision and make an
announcement before the end of the month
uh go ahead
um i know you said you didn't like
military questions too much but no i
love military questions i'm just not
going to outline military movements from
here okay fine um because
one uh one um one kind of salient
aspect is helping has been actually
openness of the us in giving military
details about what the russians are up
to so i'm wondering if you can go a
little further with that um it seems
important that people don't really
understand like
these you know the so-called
peacekeepers like how many are there are
they in donbass now is it a handful of
people is it a few guys with like you
know jeeps or is it tons of tanks
missiles but
i i don't think americans really have a
good idea of what
it is what this invasion actually
consists of sure and i appreciate and
another question
would be um
uh there's obviously no u.s trainers in
in ukraine anymore
um will this training military training
relationship continue in the third
country
sure on the second i would point you to
the department of defense who's best
equipped to answer that question um on
the first it's a really important one uh
you know i think it's important for the
american public who may be just tuning
in to know that there has been a
military russian military presence in
ukraine uh since back to 2014 which they
never admitted they never acknowledged
in some ways they've only recently
acknowledged back in 2014 and in the
years after we called them the little
green men because they were not in
russian military uniform uh now we know
that they are all over uh eastern
ukraine um and they are uh well not in
uniform they are behaving just like
russian military would be behaving um so
that is something i can't give you a
number or specifics from here because i
can't get into intelligence but it is
important for the american people to
know that that that regardless of
whether they're in uniform or not
they've been there since 2014 they are
representing uh the russian government
uh they are separatists who are we
probably should stop calling them
peacekeepers because they are certainly
not that uh who are uh you know helping
to um lay the predicate for war and that
is what the purpose of a lot of them is
there for
anything in the last 24 hours i think
that's that's really the question yes
i'm not gonna i'm not going to be able
to give you any additional assessment of
that at this point in time from here
but i understand your question will
continue to work to give you more go
ahead thanks john two quick questions on
nordstrom 2.
the first is the deputy director just
said that stopping nordstrom 2 relieved
europe of a geostrategic chokehold that
russia would have had on them so
if nordstrom 2 going online was such a
threat
why in may did the president wave
sanctions on the company and the chief
executive behind it and my second
question is
is there
a concern
that
nordstrom 2 if russia were to make
concessions or
retreat in some way that that might open
up the door to nordstrom 2 going back
online or is it your understanding that
it is dead no matter what russia does
well i would first say that um you know
the president has never been a supporter
of nordstrom 2. we've always uh
criticized it as a as a a project that
we didn't support we took a range of
steps and sanctions including sanctions
to make that very clear
what the announcement made by the german
chancellor today was
not by accident it was at the conclusion
of a range of diplomatic engagement and
efforts by the president and members of
our national security team in unity
from the europeans about the fact that
this could not move forward we've never
felt the president didn't feel that
issuing pre-emptive sanctions on that
was the right step to take
but look where we are nordstrom 2 is not
moving forward and by the way it hasn't
been operational anyway so you know
that's a fact that's not moving forward
at this point in time in terms of the
future we've never felt it was a good
project we've been clear about that and
that assessment i don't expect would
change in the future go ahead
thank you jen does the white house any
have any reaction to former president
trump calling putin's move yesterday
genius and smart
well as a matter of policy uh we try not
to take advice from anyone who praises
president putin and his military
strategy which i believe is what
happened there expresses an openness to
lifting sanctions about the seizing of
territory and crimea uh or at any point
in time told leaders of the g7
that crimea is a part of russia
regardless if they are a former
president so there's a bit of a
different tactic a bit of a different
approach and that's probably why
president biden and not his predecessor
was able to rally the world and the
global community in taking steps against
uh against russia's aggression is there
any fear that savings like that could
turn support for ukraine into a more
partisan issue among the u.s public
by the former president
you know i think that is up to members
of the republican party to make the
decision to make the determination
it has there has a long history decades
of history which president biden was a
part of when he was chairman of the
foreign relations committee of standing
up to the efforts of any country to
seize the territory of another country
uh standing up for efforts by the united
states to rally global support uh
against um against uh inappropriate uh
and illegal actions by another country
there's a long history of that not in a
partisan way in a bipartisan way and
certainly that choice is up to
republicans to make to determine go
ahead thank you i've got two questions
quickly um the administration rolled out
a list of sanctions against russian
oligarchs and elites um my question is
are any of them being sanctioned for the
first time or are these sort of repeat
bad offenders that's a good question i'm
sure we can get you a breakdown of that
i believe some of them are new um and
certainly the banks are new but let us
get you a more specific breakdown of
that my second question is the last time
jake sullivan was here he said that a
russian invasion of ukraine would lead
to u.s sanctions warning that that
wouldn't necessarily make moscow more
beholden
to beijing obviously both of those
foreign powers aren't exactly the most
friendly to us so is the administration
taking any steps uh or issuing any
warnings to keep those geopolitical foes
from
you know aligning together and marching
that locks well long before uh the
events of the last few months we saw
china and russia moving closer together
in some capacity but right now as we're
looking at the actions of president
putin and the uh as we're preparing for
him to further invade uh ukraine to uh
to uh unfortunately put forward death
and destruction on the country and the
people of ukraine it's really a question
for china on whether they look at that
and think that's acceptable behavior so
i think you saw that our secretary of
state had a conversation with his
counterpart in the last 24 or 48 hours
and we will certainly remain and
continue to engage but i think it's
about looking at where the global
community is in this moment and
determining where you want to stand
uh
okay go ahead thanks jen i wanted to ask
about rapid covent tests do you have an
update at this point on how many you've
shipped and how many of under contract
i believe we do uh but i'm gonna have to
get that to you after the briefing um we
have uh let me get that to you after the
briefing because i think we have some
updated numbers on that i think we're
gonna have to wrap up shortly here go
ahead in the back thank you thank you
i'm
for a moment but so if somebody asked
this question i'm sorry
but i would like to clarify what dali
said
at the beginning he said that
uh not sim 2
will go to waste now
so do you have assurance from germany
that uh it's the decision to cancel the
product is final or it's still
reversible
well i i would really i don't have
anything to build on beyond what uh the
strong statements and the strong
comments of the chancellor uh this
morning and the president's own
statements about how it would not move
forward okay thanks everyone we'll see
you tomorrow
there's like there's a ghost
photographer in the walls
where's doug mills
[Music]
you